you
[Music]
so it's my pleasure to introduce today
David color
David color is the professor of computer
science and a member of the faculty the
EECS faculty at UC Berkeley he received
his BA from UC Berkeley and a master's
and PhD from MIT he has served as
co-director of Berkeley's data science
planning initiative which is the main
reason why we are collaborating within
these days he's been a chair of the eeks
department a faculty director of the
citrus sustainable infrastructure
initiative and founding director of
inter research at Berkeley he won the
okawa prize in 2013 and is a member of
the National Academy of Engineering an
ACM fellow and an I to believe fellow he
was named one of scientific American's
top 50 researchers and the creator of
one of MIT technology review stent
technologies that will change the world
it's a real honor to have you here today
David we started working with David
about three years ago through our
collaboration with amp lab and it's been
fascinating to see the evolution of the
data science education initiative that
you have led at UC Berkeley and how it
has touched you know the lives of every
undergrad at UC Berkeley thank you for
being here oh thank you
Thank You Bonnie a bit of an
understatement yeah bonnie showed up on
some visit to amp levin got a little
indication of what we were doing and a
check arrived in the mail the next day
and we had credits and we were off and
running so she and the team have been
invaluable so this is the first time
i've given this talk or anything like it
in fact i've never had a chance to talk
on this topic for more than about 20
minutes so i took the chance to expand
it a little bit but i'm also hoping that
this is much more of a discussion so
i've got a good bit of material but i
hope we can do this interactively this
rather bold title i think we're in this
transformational moment I in my abstract
I said a little we're in a once in 50
year kind of time in the life of the
research university and you know the
other two where the land grant Act in
1872 and you know the combination of the
GI Bill and the rise of physics so it's
at that scale if you look anywhere
throughout the country you see this
incredible angst and turmoil about the
nature of the data revolution and how
it's really kind of causing universities
to rethink what they do and how they're
organized and what does it mean to teach
and you know it's part of that broader
so that's been going on largely driven
by students so one part of it where to
begin back in 2014 we form the data
science education Rapid Action Team to
in some sense step back and say if
you're really thinking of this as a part
of what it means to be educated in the
21st century as well as the more focused
needs of emerging research and Industry
how would you really think about it from
scratch so this was the the charge to
this Rapid Action Team faculty from not
just the EECS SES but history and
physics and political science and
information really across the board so
what came out of that well a new course
we'll talk about foundations if this is
really so fundamentally important it
begins from the moment you set foot on
campus why would you create one you
would create dozens this sense of
connector courses all fill more of this
but just take a little glance at the
subject matter of the data science
courses this term at the freshman level
so and you've all seen the analyses from
McKinsey and this that and the other and
and
the great shortage so this is what data
science looks like at Berkeley in so
here's kind of a scale we've gone from 0
to 1200 enrollments a semester 2000
students in two years in that
foundations course those connectors and
creating a whole set of advanced courses
and whatnot so I want to talk a little
bit about what's driving this how its
come where it came from but I thought so
just two days ago the students put out a
video this is following Vani and Leila
did this amazing Microsoft video which I
also have to show you if you haven't
seen but I thought I ought to begin by
just letting the students kind of speak
for themselves so let's see if we
succeed here me data science is this
really exciting new field that empowers
people to really explore any question
that may interest that certainly is
Berkeley I can feel this way obviously
the vision that every student regardless
of the stage here idea that immigrant
can be exposed to data critically okay
here so we'll do it this way data
science was that immediately saw how
applicable it was to everything else I
was learning from analyzing neural
networks in my cognitive science or kept
pretty glaring about how it is used to
predict and interpret election results
in the news
actually I thought that day would be
business like wall - by the design a
minor currently in the class I am
working on the project analyzing data on
the average in America creating
information from sites like Yelp and
Google to turn his location coffee shops
and parks and ESS turbans happiest parts
of this basic data science is already
transforming the academic environment
across all sorts of field historians now
have the ability to read previously
illegible documents and ecologists can
model population that much largest is
the kids are working on data science are
often really kind of time connections so
whenever I also clear study so I see a
lot of questions you know from a student
who studied political science and taking
a data science course about trying to
understand how the ideas of infidels can
really connect in or to become capable
of doing interesting things really early
on in project countenance any
correlations between water usage data in
public as well as like income data for
China came to people with higher incomes
use more or less water than people with
lower incomes and it's just so
interesting both the data gave us any
feed over to my mind so like the
probability theory and all inner
workings of data and associations work
at so-called so it's a really powerful
way to get the underlying truth of
what's going on in the world around us
not bad
okay well if we have time I'll come back
and show you the Microsoft one to it
[Music]
yeah yeah go away interesting okay so
where did this begin
so of course how could you be talking
about this without stepping back and and
remembering Jim right so so much of this
began back in 2000 where Jim and and
Alex and
really began to recognize how this is
completely shaping yet Kent's heart so
that in of course more recently you know
Jim was always fifteen years ahead of
his time and he certainly was on this
within Berkeley you know of course in
that timeframe absolutely every field
you know throughout the nation was being
transformed from data poor to data rich
we know that and you know in 2012 with
the presidential big data initiative and
amply band X data and that you know
coming from the technical side as we
launched into the more Sloan grant
process that gave rise to the Berkeley
Institute of data science they had us it
wouldn't let us write a proposal how
does take inventory and you know what
you saw was that that picture on the top
had already pervaded the university of a
three hundred faculty that showed up a
moment's notice to participate in that
and moves absolutely everywhere but
there was this other message for me that
came through which was those faculty
were saying that grad students I need to
recruit into my lab for the next project
the places that are actually at the
frontiers of my field there is no
undergraduate education in the world
that is preparing them for that so you
know in some sense the most basic
mission of the research university of
training the next generation of
researchers a gap had opened in that we
and we generally across the entire world
had had failed and we see this as well D
lab is a social science data lab 2500
grad students a year showing up there of
course the students had seen this long
ago this is a picture of the black line
there is the total number of freshmen
the colors are the enrollment in the
introductory computer science courses
and the orange is in statistics courses
and you could go look at the majors in
CS or in statistics and a huge fraction
of those are also double and of course
all of this was just the University
microcosm of what was going on in in the
rest of the world so the blueprint well
okay so the question was how do you
orient that university that instrument
now to begin to really make this a
fundamental part of all college
education so you can think of this as
it's 6,000 students wide it's four years
high and you know today it's populated
with a bunch of majors and courses and
whatnot so the concept was from the
moment you arrived as a freshman really
this integrated experience of
computational thinking inferential
thinking in the context of real-world
problems make that available and
accessible to the entire student body
I didn't say make it a requirement how
do you that's the question of scale is a
question of access but really a modern
way of thinking also recognizing no
matter how brilliant a job you did with
that you could not do justice to the
incredible diversity of interests and
background of the student body of a
world-leading public university so take
a more modular approach so the idea we
invented there was this notion of
connectors that would be little to unit
freshmen courses they'd be taken ideally
at the same time and they would be in
all sorts of different fields and you
say oh my god how could you ever do that
then faculty would actually have to look
at each other's syllabi in order to zip
them together and the answer is yes
that's exactly right they would actually
have to pay attention but so at the very
least this would be the new student
experience that that introduction and
they go on through their program but and
of course you know you'd have to think
through how do you adapt to the k-12 and
not everybody's ready to do that and so
forth this is really subversive because
what we're really empowering faculty to
do
is to then introduce data analytics
modules throughout the program so that
the more typical course of a student
would come back to this knowledge they
work so hard to learn and you know give
faculty license throughout but also if
you imagine if you've got three thousand
students a year going a semester six
thousand students a year and maybe these
are smaller courses maybe only a hundred
you've got 50 60 70 faculty a year that
are actually throughout campus teaching
as a part of this program and that
begins to infect all of those other
fields because it's a generational
turnover and then of course you go build
a major and we'll talk more about that
and we had this concept of really
building at the upper division when
you've gained scientific maturity
mathematical maturity pure and simple
maturity you know what you wore what you
want to be and that that might be a
deeper experience that would be part of
all sorts of different majors or a major
in data science that would draw upon
some of the concentrations being the
statistical and mathematical the systems
and and engineering the social
implications and that out of that you
could draw upon a minor and we usually
think of those things as orthogonal to
their major but in this world that's
probably not the right way to think
about it you'd like to engage the major
so the capstone of the minor might well
be offered in the major that it comes
from drawing data back into that pursuit
perhaps into them so that was our
blueprint I was asked today how are we
doing well from day one the students
have been asking this will this be ready
in time for me so we've been laying the
tracks as students or running along
trying to get a hold of them so that's
introduction what I thought I'd do is
spend a chunk of time talking about this
data eight core
to give you a sense of that touch on
some of these connectors touch on we're
now piloting that upper division gateway
des 100 and give you a little little
sense of it so that plan for the time
ahead this began as a pretty broad
collaboration seven faculty from eek
stat information school over the spring
while the university couldn't figure out
any of this to go create is fundamental
commingling of the cs and stat concepts
on real data so you know you learn
computing while you're doing something
interesting with data you learn
statistical concepts why observing
what's interesting and that kind of
turning the conceptual process around
where those symbolic views of it rather
than a bunch of formulas really serve to
codify the intuition and then this is
punctuated through explorations so this
is you know just a little taste you know
students at the freshman level doing
bootstrapping and hypothesis testing in
a classical stat program you'd be lucky
if you got there as a senior okay so I
thought so these two faculty from
Statten CS tend to ping-pong
although each of them does a fair amount
of lectures in support of the other and
we get to mix in so I thought I'd let
ani Adhikari speak for herself so I
brought her with me today and so she
offers a view from a statistics
perspective look there's three mic steps
formulating the question and Method is
hugely important the visualization and
calculation and interpretation of this
in domains of mixes and on II would say
the common approach in statistics has to
take all of that and reduce it to that
all focus on the calculation she's very
proud of the Berkeley statistics history
with Friedman and so forth of really
emphasizing the rest of that and you
know what's happened here bringing us
full circle is that it's not just a
matter of formulas that it's really
putting the emphasis on the problem as a
whole but not get so hung up on the
calculations and said really utilize the
power of computation to to appreciate
that ok you can see this is easier to
say from a stat point of view it was
very cute when when John was giving
these slides Ben you another staff
member was very anxious about their
first one who's ready to come in and
defend it okay so so ok accessibility so
we've had a lot of conversations back
and forth you know exactly what are they
learning about as you were and so forth
the notion here is everything is focused
on the pedagogical concept of what they
need to know so what do you begin with a
browser period no files no Studios no
compilers no nothing you have a browser
you can go compute so that's been
everything is in a jupiter notebook all
of the lectures the textbook itself all
of the labs they've never seen anything
else right they carry a computer around
that doesn't mean you compute so for
their point of view the world lives
there now one of the things we did at
the beginning and I'll do a little bit
more on this was to create a data frames
abstraction that if you will took all
that intuition you developed you know
since you were in third grade working
with Excel and they do since third grade
right so this is an ordered list of
named columns but you never read pandas
documentation or matplotlib or numpy or
any of the rest we'll say a little bit
more
and yes it's in Python so you have one
powerful data structure that does
absolutely everything and it's even easy
to underestimate how big a change
learning to compute in a notebook
environment is and I'm the child of one
of the earliest interactive computing
but for what does it mean that for these
students computing is part of a kind of
digital narrative it's a computational
essay in general it begins with a
question and access to some raw data and
proceeds through a series of steps of
distilling and formulating arguments and
computational reasoning to arrive at a
conclusion that's very different from
it's a bunch of stuff that happens in
solving puzzles and so this notion that
it's presented before them in a kind of
literary way actually makes a huge
difference to huge segments of the
population that might not have come out
of a traditional Cs environment okay and
of course part of it is make sure you
can do all of that with a really rich
mix of data so it's not just numbers its
text it's its shapes its images its we
haven't actually done sounds in video
but we talked about that a lot okay so
everything about the program as a whole
is on data berkeley.edu everything about
the course is a data aid org all of the
offerings I've given you a little bit of
a snapshot but I encourage you to go
there and look at it yourself where you
could actually read it you almost have
to look at it to to see this kind of
interweaving of computational and
statistics and how far they go I'll do a
little bit more but what that misses is
the thing that's really important
drawing sound conclusions about
populations you cannot
observe from the samples of them that
you have and it's amazing how that
deeply that's lost but this is all about
the inference part right not just the
calculation but how do I generalize that
to the original problem
so everywhere throughout it comes back
to that that question okay so here's a
sharp a little bit of a higher level
view of what's in there and okay so you
know beginning with really the what and
why starting very early on with
understanding causality as opposed to
correlation and experimental process yes
they learn programming in Python and the
set of sequence types so basically they
see tables and numpy erase tables and
erase numbers this is actually kind of
interesting because it has all of the
relational operators built into it so
you know the step to sequel is some
weird syntax really understanding
randomness and probability from working
about it so it's not about p-values and
T sets it's about empirical p-values so
so many of those really difficult
concepts come out of it naturally you
don't start by learning formulas you
don't learn one statistic you learn a
whole family of statistics it's not just
mean there's lots of them you learn
those higher order things you can do
with statistics like permutation tests
and other kind of evaluations about the
right statistics hypothesis testing to
where they really understand because
they've been simulating it what a null
hypothesis is and so they're being
driven by bootstrapping and permutation
test from very early on so you can think
of this as a set of first half of
building the to up so that then you
really can get into prediction
classification
and learning at that freshman level okay
so this is pretty interesting if you're
not presupposing that you have calculus
much less linear algebra and yet you
want to get them all the way where they
can do meaningful jobs of doing
inference yeah we're X itself getting
into the university okay and it's a 1/4
class reporters one semester so 15 weeks
so has statistics or a cop side high
school or who cares who cares
both of those are considered a challenge
rather than an opportunity because a
huge amount of it is unlearning what
they might have learned there I'll show
you some data of that mix and and yes
the thing we know about computer science
course of the the hacker jock that wants
to show all they compute there is a
similar one of we know all of these
definitions of things so a lot of it is
unwinding that to get back to
understanding sound inferences about
that which you can't see directly
tsai-tien a CT scores tell you about
your incoming preparation mathematically
for this any this so there's no question
this was an issue this is built for
absolutely everybody at Berkeley which
is an incredibly high bar across the
board I'll show you some of the stats
you know there's 70 different majors
represented in this student pool we're
only now beginning to track them through
so every week so then you get into
really how do you construct this so
Monday Wednesday Friday you have a
one-hour lecture now at the scale of 700
students that was also this semester was
500 last semester it will be a thousand
next semester between the Wednesday
lecture and the Friday lecture you have
two hour
hands-on labs that are carefully tuned
to take the thing that from Friday
through Wednesday you've been learning
and now master it so it's running like
clockwork and you notice if you go back
to that syllabus huh
every single lecture draws upon some
interesting piece of data or - it's
carefully chosen to bring out the
concepts that you're getting - there
it's been fascinating over the four
semesters to see I mean these two people
are brilliant instructors and how
they've refined it so I'll show you a
little piece of that as now the data
sets even recurred throughout the
semester so you get a sense of your own
intellectual progress throughout so the
emphasis is on visual understanding by
computational means and it's a rigorous
course but the formalisms come out from
the observation i sat in through the
first pilot I thought when the central
limit theorem finally came out the
students were you know going to say
hallelujah so there's three major
projects in addition to these weekly
things I'll give you a taste of the
current ones and then punctuated with
these explorations into social questions
that are raised throughout to keep that
conversation going so dig in just a
little deeper okay so I actually think
what we've done with tables is more than
just a tool for teaching but it's
beautiful for that so one data structure
to do everything you need at the early
stage to learn the really hard subtle
stuff that gets you into pandas secret
so don't try to compete with everything
our ever thought about it's an ordered
collection of labelled columns of
anything which means if I index it I get
an array which means the entire world of
scifi and whatnot I can gracefully
without ever reading any of that begin
to work with of course a row of that is
your record your dictionary your tupple
the rest of those things that
used to so the columns are homogeneous
and type and length basically you can
point a table to almost any data in the
world stick it into a table and you know
do all of the visualization that you
would like to do and and this is all
folium and matplotlib and whatnot
tomorrow it may turn into plotly or d3
or whatnot that can continue to evolve
so really quickly on students begin to
point the data suck it into a table
start to visualize it and then it's to
do interesting things with it which has
been all the operators so the first
thing you do is to provide all the
relational operators you don't need to
have query processing and a lot of
sophistication there to get there so
they're now very comfortable with
slicing and dicing this and putting it
together in various ways including
joints so you can start to take
different data sources and put them
together but then you also throw in all
of the statistical operators so of
course bins or histograms but how about
taking a sample a random sample you know
or a permutation so most of the things
that they might ever think to do they
can do on a table from the beginning and
and you could learn a little bit from
excel that some of those non-traditional
operators like pivots and whatnot we're
actually really important which allows
you to take values and turn them into
labels and back and forth so that's it
everything they do you can do that in a
lecture at early on and then just use it
throughout so that's one of the things
that's in github it does live on top of
so you can go back and forth to pandas
or CSVs questions there
of course I what's underneath the
question what do you mean because you're
going to continue to evolve this right
yeah so um what happens here is not so
much where it's back because all these
things end up being in memory anyways so
it's more a question how much Pandits is
under do you try to do all of this as a
thin layer over pandas and whatnot we
ended up choosing not to do any of that
and it's actually I'm really happy about
that
because what's underneath this is also a
really great the rest of what you need
to learn in your first and second
semester or right there in the
implementation of it so it's actually
quite nice that it's built from scratch
which is another I should say the one of
the things that's come out of our
computer science program was this notion
of if not teaching you a fixed set of
things it's empowering you to realize
anything you could want need to use you
could build yourself and so we wanted to
take that notion you're not just a
consumer of data you're a producer but
it's a consumer producer in a chain
because what you produce somebody else
may consume and that's true for the
technology as well as the data product
and really get that pro sumer concept to
be in there from the beginning the other
piece is kind of related to that the
only way any of these things are
possible was this change of student
culture and this happened first in the
computer science program during the
downturn we grew as fast as we did
before the internet bubble and during
the recovery we grew it three times that
rate and the only way it was possible
was this student this culture of
students teaching students so students
take the course they then grade for the
course and then a lab assistant and then
they ta the course are incredibly
influential
but they also develop a lot of the
technology so we built that into the
data science program for the date first
from day one so the you got to build
this pipeline so the first semester was
a hundred students but those students
became and we've actually had a whole
student team studying students doing
essentially market validation within the
student body asking those questions that
only students can ask of each other and
filtering it back so almost all the
technology here is also a student built
John and I got our hands a little bit in
this before the students toured away
from us this is a taste of the three
project this term the last term they did
was during the drought that was timely
so this beautiful one early on looking
at you know why can't we solve world
hunger and hence Rosling died this this
year so it's also sort of a tribute to
him the notion of natural experiments so
this is looking you know the us-canada
border ends up being this wonderful
natural experiment if you will in this
very terrible question of so they end up
looking at pretty deep social issues and
you know the the the pieces that are
down underneath that you know is about
is the thing that you're observing you
know really a matter of the population
or the sample you're taking of the
population you know getting into really
understanding how to formulate a
hypothesis test and draw conclusions
this one's end up being a k-nearest
neighbors exercise so classification
with the set of mathematical skills
where you basically can take averages of
things and it's pretty pretty sweet
questions Jane in history students
it's an interesting one to measure the
self-reported workload is within norms
so that was really important
all students are quite challenged by
something in it so I'll show you the
demographics a little bit which really
tried to build this for freshmen
we're disciplined with that but it's got
juniors and seniors and graduate
students and faculty in it and even
those find that there it's worth their
while it's quite challenging so this was
a really interesting you know with the
students that we have it's really
important to challenge them and at the
same time you're really trying not to
threaten them right so it needs to be a
gateway not a gatekeeper so we think the
answer is just right for our students
but it's a ongoing question sure so
looks beautiful is there any downside
his approach to students maybe never go
back and get more the fundamentals a
need for statistics or computer science
does it hurt them somewhere in the
future yes um too early to tell not so
there's no question this is way better
than any statistics course that we've
ever offered so one example of that we
went back there 22 programs that had a
statistics requirement and 20 of them
now accept this or because you get to
the other what we did one of the
connectors is a statistics I call them
the day d8 that do the rest of the
theory you would have got in the
introductory statistics for majors and I
taught a similar course on the CS side
so you could take four units of classic
intro to CS and four units of classic
eight units or you could take this and
two units of the two connectors so a
couple of the majors like econ require a
combination so I'd say absolutely no
downside in that respect you'll see some
other data
students love this they got their really
excited they're beating us up for not
having a major soon enough yeah so I
thought I would take just one vignette
of this question of how do you really
approach this differently when you try
to because I've given shorter
presentations you know followed by NYU's
master's program where the answer is
what we basically cover what Berkeley is
doing in their freshman course which is
true so you know how do you actually do
it that early so I thought I would take
this kind of classic you know if and how
is y related to X your your classic
prediction question so in week 3 lecture
10 where they're learning functions
right there's they've gotten through you
know iteration and expressions and learn
tables a little bit and they're seeing
the power of functions and truly going
back to at the days of Darwin Darwin's
cousin you know with all of the eugenics
you know and so that 1800 data about the
heights of parents or the average height
of the parents of the predictor of the
heights of the child and and surely you
can so of course you could plot it and
early on you can start that question of
gee there seems to be a relationship
here and of course you don't just breed
ever more bigger people and you can
start teasing them in this question okay
yeah is plotting tilt into the table yes
cool yeah so you drop it into a table
you can plot it you can scatter it you
can histogram it you can build and
anything you can do all to also produce
a new table right so whether it's a
histogram or a bin so yes that's all
built in and you might ask could you put
a fit of line through this well you're
saying well what does it mean
for these things to be related so I
found my sophomore text on linear
algebra I thought it was great actually
this I think first edition of Gil Strang
you know this question of an over
constrained system
does this problem actually arise in
practical applications and you know how
would I project this vector onto the
column space and is it numerically
stable and then it goes on from there
right so what happens instead is you
could say oh you know it is a nice
function if I took a height I could take
sort of the points around the space and
I could take that average as a
prediction of the child heights from and
then I get those points so that's a
little exercise in functions taking some
average and you might so you know they
get to write this you may notice
selection is built into tables you know
as and you know you can have another
operator here so there they're learning
about that but they're being teased by
this question so six weeks later they've
learned statistics they've learned
empirical distributions they learn
sample means they've learned confidence
interval holes built on those empirical
means variations they've understood and
they got correlation coefficients so
they've seen those peaches and once you
convert it over into standard units then
this relationship is just the
correlation coefficient so then it's
that line and how there's a different
and if you do one little change of
variables another little computing
exercise then you get the line that
would come out of it which you can then
compare with what you learned at the
beginning okay that got you regression
but then you want to come back to
to that slope is that real or is that
just an artifact of the sample that
you've had so at the next lecture all
right so we've changed different data
set we could here I've switched over to
one that happens to have a bunch of data
on maternal characteristics and child
birth weight gestation maternal age
height pregnancy weight whether they
smoke what and at this point can I just
do a little demo okay so what I do in
five minutes what would be a 50 minute
lecture in this and they'll give you a
sense of the tools okay so this you can
see so let's scroll down here and I'm
going to grab this lecture on sample
means linear regression least squares
residuals regression inference that
slope that I seem to appear is it real
and so I'm going to go open that that
went a little fast so this is what the
students have seen throughout boom you
notice what I have I'm living in my hub
you can actually sort of see me this
particular lecture in there I fired off
an instance I've cloned from github down
into my personal space in this over
kubernetes on some cloud somewhere in
the world ok and let me make that can
you sort of read that let's make it
bigger ok that's probably reasonable let
me go ahead and clear all of this and
and kind of start from scratch ok so
there's a little bit of stuff that you
bring in basically that data science
that you import in this particular case
that set of mathematics that's on the
slide is now captured in some very
simple functions that they've been
building up themselves for doing that so
they would have had that built in
they made here's a little this one
happens to develop this notion of
regression and and to talk about
inference a little bit more so we have a
little simulation where if I took things
that were in some relationship and threw
in some noise here's the line that was
truth in that Oracle world and the data
but what I see is actually this and what
my fit was giving me that and so I can
talk about the relationship between the
regression line and the true line all
right this is the real message
underneath okay so you bring that out
and if you like you can show that you
know if you use a lot more points than
that relationship is is more realistic
and you know for a thousand points okay
so we've already got this notion of
reality versus what we're observing and
now we go back and we take a data set in
this case all that information about
babies and births and whatnot and of
course we might want to look at what
that is
so that's built in there's the
distribution of birth weights and
gestational days and if only
obstetricians understood statistics
wouldn't life be okay and we could plot
their relationships we could see yeah
there does seem to be a relationship
between how many weeks and how large and
what is that and and at this point they
understand the residual and they could
go pull that out almost half an ounce
per day is that slope and the question
is is that real so you could imagine if
you so here they're doing bootstrapping
where this operator is giving them a
sample with replacement of that same
data set so that you can be
and now let's do that a few times
well they look kind of similar but and
you know every one of those had the same
oven 74 but with permutations so if I
did that thousands of times okay let's
go to at 5000 times and it'll take about
16 seconds so you know we wouldn't have
done this years ago but what will come
back is I'll get a table which contains
all the slopes okay great
here I have the distribution of the
slopes from thousands of samples
bootstrapping from that population and
of course at this point you know I can
turn that into a function I could do
that I could look at bootstrapping the
slope I could look at the residuals okay
oh I see what I've got ahead of myself a
little bit so I could go ahead and say
look here's the 95% confidence interval
I can really say quite confidently about
this property of that population whereas
if I asked what is the effect of
maternal age on gestation days I might
get something that looks like it had a
line to it but if I really go and look
at that I cannot reject the null
hypothesis okay so they're getting quite
a lot of power quite early on this
experience to really come back to that
those original questions this particular
one goes off now to do a better job of
prediction so okay if I've got 300 days
of pregnancy what's the distribution of
dates I can look give you a sense so
that's kind of a typical day in data
eight
but you can see it's built up over ten
weeks of experience yeah how and when
how to do without liars like you know
sometime clear outliers you know you
have to clean your data bit okay so
there are several pieces of that B so
what we don't do in this course is data
wrangling we've been very careful to
prepare things you know there's lots of
outliers in this data set
tons of them which is you the other is
develop statistical techniques or
computational statistic techniques that
are very robust to outliers and this is
a great example of that we didn't have
any conversation about what distribution
this was so that is part of it is these
kind of modern techniques are also very
resilient in that respect to projects
you don't you steer them away from data
wrangling how cuz they get totally
wrapped up I'm not entirely so what
happens there is it varies a lot by
instructor in the in the courses so some
of them have chosen to in the later on
very important but really easy to get to
get lost in that okay so okay
just in case we didn't get to do demo we
had it here so part of what I wanted to
show there you could you can imagine
what does it take to import this course
well I can run all of that which you put
her on my machine
okay go at it and I get all of the joys
of all of the different machines
of course at modest scale you stand up
at Jupiter hub and at add what is also
here is a whole bunch of other tools for
doing Auto grading for doing mastery
learning a bunch of other things have
been developed around that ecosystem so
now what we do and this has been part of
the pacing is that's all dr. eyes on top
of a kubernetes so we have lot we can
have lots of different hubs for
different parts of the curriculum that
have different underlying images and it
integrates directly into the campus
authentication so this looks as much a
part of the student experience it's way
easier than signing up for a course and
basically all of the workflow goes
through github so the the instructor is
essentially pushing or their materials
and when I touch that link it went out
and it cloned into my workspace there if
you will from the repository for the
particular course and that allows you to
support the fact that the materials of
students ease evolves week by week and
and so forth so this has been a lot of
the conversation with Vaughn Ian's team
and so forth about you know the
readiness of various platforms the
Business School is standing up this
stuff this summer but they have to run
it on their own clusters because they're
the business school whatever that and we
do - yeah questions please question
about the things you dancers I thought
they're just a part of the provision of
sentences that try to find it you will
be lucky to get these kind of techniques
as a senior there's no question that the
notion the virgil's in your foreign
language we're doing visualizations but
the techniques things like that they'd
be tested thank you there's no question
that a t-test is not going to go away
you know how am I sure that this is
different than that and regression is
not going to go away
but you know part of the you know when
we do it in the upper division course
then it looks like this right it's about
how do I minimize the loss function over
this space and you know we do the whole
bit on that the question is how do I
robustly put it in students hands even
before they've had calculus
so that you know then they're prepared
to do it they and they certainly haven't
had linear algebra yet is pushing stuff
like pushing it down and more robust
computational techniques you know they
see not an idealization of the data but
the actual data which moves you away
from a whole set of traditional
statistical approaches to these
computational approaches so try to find
bootstrap and permutation test in the
textbooks write much less how do I take
that and derive peeve out empirical
p-values I mean we didn't do a student
t-test anywhere in here which means you
don't have a lot of conversations about
those yet yeah like this is what our per
day is yours so there for research so
there's three one-hour lectures and 1/2
hour lab in a given week and the lab
will be in the second one and I haven't
got the connectors yet but they will
tend to be in the Monday Tuesday so that
the week will ends up being split
between us
in general they are yeah and how many
the students per Section or lab so 25
that's a lot of T days right so what
happens this is why it is a lot of TAS
but each of those labs will typically
have ta lab assistant and often other
helpers and then we've kind of carefully
done the physical layout of those so
that there's pods of groups and you can
see where people are so there's a
certain art to that too I wanted to give
you a sense of the explorations so Dave
Wagner did one on informational privacy
is a great example and part of what
you're seeing here is the mix of media
and whatnot so what he does is starts
with license plates readings out of the
Oakland Police Department which are the
own interesting you know a
California Public Information requests
out of the Electronic Frontier
Foundation and ACLU lawsuits you know
this question of what is public it was
observed in the public that it belonged
to the public into it it now is public
and you take that data and you know you
throw it on to a map which again you can
do with the table because it's a table G
is perfectly good kind of data and you
look at all of that you immediately see
it's not uniform over the city it's
concentrated in certain parts of town oh
okay lots near the police station and if
you wanted to do the correlation with
socioeconomic status you'd see
correlations there too but what he does
is he takes a newspaper article on the
mayor of Oakland who got a lot of
parking tickets and it shows her license
plate sees filtered for the license
plate and you see oh yeah a lot of time
around the courthouse and this and then
it also goes over here a lot you say hmm
let's look for patterns like that okay
who spends a lot of time near the fire
station oh that might be the fire chief
and oh we're due else do we see them and
oh they look like they have they're all
in Little League field so there's a
point about 20 minutes into this lecture
where the students feel I'm invading
somebody's privacy on public data okay
so we're trying to teach judgment it's
not this is illegal it's not this but it
has to make it right and so it opens up
these really important questions about
the data just because you have it versus
your personal responsibility so here's
what the demographics look like this was
for last semester we were slightly
majority female I and significant no
response so maybe like out of the 500
students 60 majors eighty five if you
count double major combination
early on I've got this for two years so
you can see so spring goes before fall
so computer science is dropping econ
psychology took off versus statistics
business cause I applied math eeks
Public Health MCB and then it just goes
on and on of a very large number of
different majors so we really have this
was a real question could would make
this work for the entire student body
yeah they do so very often it's specific
things a part of that was waking up to
it
part of that was getting some of these
other pieces a big part of it was their
advisors said go take it now in that
particular course they also advised them
to take the methods course that was
being taught in our at the very same
time and that was actually not a very
good idea so things can get a little
complicated but so it actually is you
know there's other questions that are
interesting like tracing these folks
going forward
yeah no programming versus strong
programming are almost people yeah yeah
okay chronic programmers tend to
immediately help their peers in the
class yeah so this is a really
interesting piece of social dynamics of
how to do that how to engineer that well
there is a sense of some of these folks
feeling a little intimidated by some of
those folks so that's been a thing that
we're continuing to work on and you also
notice here although we were majority
first and second-year seniors and
juniors grad students and and others the
from ethnicity point of view it
basically models campus
against the insurgency has it exceed on
the doctor the gender yeah so we're
making huge progress on death of course
it's nowheres near this blend in fact if
you look in this semester the ratio here
is down to about 44 percent female in
large part because it is a larger influx
from that class so we actually are
getting close to parity there after
quite a long time but you have nothing
like well it's also now 2500 students to
summer school for high school students
are connecting with Dan Garcia which is
outreach efforts around enjoy computing
and yeah so um this summer we're doing a
pre data 8 as part of the summer edge
program which is mostly bringing
students in from minority serving
schools we're also doing a summer
offering of this course yeah comment
early in your talk you today that
students this it's not required that the
course is available how how students get
to know about data aid from students
yeah so we've really tried to get that
outreach happening so part of this
student group is also communicating to
students the buzz is happening so down
the line it it you know all students
should take this but it's so much better
to make it really popular and important
and then to worry about the last few
percent than it is to try to force it
down their throats from the beginning
Annie shared me some of the responses so
I shall share those before I go on to
other topics which I guess will do a
little bit so
yes
so it's interesting you know with this
very empirical approach the perspective
is it's really about concepts this was
coming oh I got to track it to there
she thought it was very interesting you
know and sometimes we tend to do puzzle
solving and so students love it okay so
the other piece of this was these
connectors and so I got a bit into that
so here I've got previously I showed you
the current semesters so this was the
previous semesters connectors which are
pretty interesting to think about I mean
you know this is taught by somebody out
of theater cognitive science there's now
an MCB connector building out some of
these are on the technical the rest of
the technical development I'll do a
little bit more coming out of demography
children in so this one is taking
household data focusing on student
health so what's happened is the
connector social network noun it's the
faculty together so it's been really
interesting to see how these develop so
you take for example I guess we didn't
have a geospatial data analysis in this
semester but we've had almost every
semester who teaches that is that
geography is that environmental science
planning management is it urban design
is it civil engineering well actually
all of them through cases like that when
the faculty take it down to basics then
faculty and other departments become
partners with their it so it's created
these networks across and in each one of
those departments there's a bunch of
other faculty that say yeah that's great
but in geography we have these four
other things that would be really great
if our students would learn so you get
those so that's kind of kicked off this
really interesting discussion that can
only happen from what
then that's somebody from data science
reaching out and want to go they're
disciplines to say here's an opportunity
and I'm going to go help you write the
curriculum on echo teach it for you
oh man such a great disciplines they
kind of pick it up on their own and not
as relying on it yes yeah so I wish we
had a nice clean it's this grassroots
chaos and we've tried very hard to have
a degree of facilitation around it so we
do weekly connector meetings I have now
an undergrad that is served previously
there was a postdoc that kind of did
some of that and you know it's a huge
amount of stuff in many cases they may
be postdocs we're starting to get more
faculty so yeah and how do you scale it
and and it was really hard when the main
course was evolving and would they admit
to what so that's been it is amazing we
succeeded like we have to get here but
part of it so the students helped a lot
in the first semester and it continues
well the the faculty teaching them we
try to do it their own way and about six
weeks in the students said why are you
doing that to me
let me show you and so what we've done
is we've sent the students out now so
they're stood a whole student group that
works with these to help them will bring
their materials in and what not so
bottom up this was a one bead SCS PhD in
a civil engineering department did one
on transportation so you kind of have a
nice picture here of the underlying
problem of this massive set of how do I
get people from an origin to a
destination viewing the Bay Area
transportation system so you know
wonderful set of things that can really
get into complicated messy got to
understand a bit get excited about
modern civil engineering another civil
engineering faculty actually the vice
chair for undergraduate matters is doing
one on time series analysis and
sea-level rise
and so what I captured for you here was
there's a sequence of quite technical
extensions to what we do in the main
course all tied in with you know this
the world that these students are
growing into so I thought I'd show you
in a little more detail one of them so
brand new faculty member into democracy
doing a social networks connector so
starts out teaching them survey methods
and very often you do this in the
connector you do things in the
discipline while they're getting some
headway in the main course about you
know where you came from and then you
begin to codify it then all of the
students from Los Angeles mostly had
friends from Los Angeles so they become
a part of their data and then at that
point
well actually this notion Muhammad Li is
well studied and we can formalize it
mathematically and we can compute with
it and we can begin to do something with
it and then they begin to go off and
coming up with their own measurements
and whatnot and start computing
properties of social networks that are
appropriate to the field and you know of
course then you bring in all these other
data sources and so this was going on
during the election and so they looked
at a bunch of relationships like
co-sponsorship of bills between
democrats and republicans and twitter
relationships amongst those so you know
begin to understand so as an example of
a kind of thing putting these together
connector questions so the questions
throughout from day one was when will
the major be ready and so last semester
John took a little survey so
sixty-six two-thirds of the students in
that 500-person class were very
interested two exceptionally two very
interested in major so there's a little
bit of demand so the way that's shaping
up is this initial experience then as
you go through your lower division you
need to develop a certain amount more
computing in mathematics to really be
able to engage more deeply as become a
data scientist while you're also doing a
lot of your breaths and the rest of your
general education take that integrative
experience codify it once again much
more deeply as you approach the upper
division where you can go into a much
greater technical depth and start
applying it to all of these real world
questions this ends up doing quite a bit
of heavy lifting because the more
advanced courses are drawing upon
existing statistics computer science ie
lower kind of courses including you know
getting them to where they can take a
really deep machine learning and so it's
not just the three bit diagrams you want
to complement that with a concentration
typically an application domain focused
in an area to do that effectively what
you actually want to do is start that
concentration in the lower division
because these advanced courses will have
some so they have to start thinking I
might want to major I should be thinking
about some of these going forward and a
social context element so this within
Berkley there's a concept of a group
major so this could actually so there's
a bunch of constraints that kick in but
the notion here is it's a it's a major
but it's carefully designed and yet
interdisciplinary about integrative that
it's both technically deep and
conceptual contextualized and grounded
in the in the real world so more on this
going to prove to be another one of
these interesting
exercise of getting faculty all on the
same page you know and you kind of have
to have it as a constrained optimization
problem because almost every faculty
member thinks that they need to do you
know forty seven units of their
specialty and you know that going to
come with the cost to something else so
notion there is to get enough structure
where there's many pass through that
students could specialize it towards
their interest while making sure that
all of those paths meet certain
guidelines so I thought I'd do a little
bit more on this data one hundred course
as part of that unless there's more
questions here on I can tell you
thoughts none of this is approved or
even close to that
so there's committee talk okay so
principles and techniques of data
science as a bridge to the upper
division so we're thinking about it a
somewhat smaller multidisciplinary team
so these four faculty most of whom you
probably know on statistics and computer
science and several of the TAS for the
course these in particular built the
data eight course and then graduated
into building the upper division course
so really focus on this notion of
empowerment but part of what's going on
is those upper division courses were
designed assuming you came through a
lower division for that major so it's
got to do a bunch of kind of impedance
matching so make sure that students are
available to tackle those as well and
part of what's really coming out and
having the stats representation really
focus on what is the experience so the
organizing principle of this course in
some sense is the data science lifecycle
and so how do we really emphasize
framing of questions exploring
understanding and and you know we all
know
that that lifecycle really looks like
that right so the I'll show you the flow
of the course the first version thought
to do a full trip around the lifecycle
early on and then go through each of it
much more carefully to go deeper so I'll
show you a bit more about that so you
know much more about preparation and
representation here it's not magic
anymore we really want to focus on
scalability and efficiency so you can
move towards tackling problems of scale
while at the same time go much more
deeply into experimental design and that
back and forth yeah there's a bit more
in the exploratory but what we're now
ready to do is to go more deeply into
the algorithmic techniques so this will
change but it's a step so what we did
was to try to do a first time through
the entire lifecycle to get all and this
is essentially the instructors working
through a data science example in some
context getting deeply so they get here
with Joe Hellerstein of course you're
going to have a significant amount of
data wrangling they get experience with
trifecta tools and putting up their
Postgres servers goes quite a bit
further in the statistical modeling and
in the machine learning and pushing it
out at scale so let's see so looking at
that integrative notion so this was kind
of pulling that aspect out of the course
the ways in which so you know bootstrap
methods for hypothesis testing in native
sequel on our ruku cloud may be an
example of an experience in a week or
using maximum likelihood
estimation for irregular data coming out
or web crawlers things like that they so
you know a bunch of different in-depth
examples for example food safety and so
forth so I figured one of the questions
would come up is okay so what
technologies to get exposed to so this
was taking a little survey of what you
know so here that's what we're after
okay so let me kind of close with
philosophizing a little bit touching on
some of the other less structured pieces
so one was this notion of supporting the
faculty as they move forward so one of
the things we've done is to put together
this faculty short course in the summer
so a week-long course where the for the
front door is focused on pedagogy and in
the process we learn what it is the
students are actually learning so this
is amazing experience with you know
faculty from Near Eastern Studies being
you know in deep in conversation with
the chair of economics and you know it
was this is a sense of this student team
supporting but part of this is to enable
faculty and lots of places to create
bite-size week-long modules so this was
a little some of the pilot modules
they're using the physical plant of the
main course they're using its tools but
they're much more focused in what the
students start with and so I give you a
little sense of so we have an American
cultures requirement so one of the
module developments was a director of
that program that took the short course
and she's now looking at it a American
cultures data
course kind of interesting piece the
other side of it is men are these
students incredible assets for research
happening everywhere on campus so we
started this whole program of getting
them connected into their research
experience and they will do things that
you can not only will the grad students
thumb their nose at it but they're not
as good at it so these are getting
pretty exciting there's also a handful
of now a number of other courses are
taking the traditional elements in some
discipline so this is a couple in
statistics both at the lower division
and a problem you know this would be the
theory course now in this so many
courses we're having this huge debate
about the math department redesigning
the linear algebra course that had half
a quarter of OD ease and PDEs and it
really ought to do PCA and and singular
value decomposition so these kind of
conversations about rethinking
traditional pieces are starting
everywhere so that kind of brings us
back to this beginning you know the
heart of a 20th century university so
you know at Berkeley we have colleges
that have a bunch of divisions divisions
is really our operational unit in
college is some kind of conceptual unit
that does admissions and graduations and
they're big areas you know the social
sciences these meta organizations and in
engineering is essentially a mono
divisional college and then we have a
bunch of professional schools that are
mono divisional schools and you know at
some level right at the heart there's no
data and computational sciences there's
no place that brings those related
disciplines together
so that's what's happening now is
creating a division and it's a really
interesting question because it's not at
all clear that it wants to be walled off
as a school or a college it wants to be
integrated with rather
differentiated from it wants to be a
part of rather than a part from even
though you know so you could put that
division in engineering or you could put
it in both but so these are what's in
it's clear you know statistics very
likely moves into that then EECS and
maybe operations research or IOR as we
call it but you know what are the pieces
that come out of quantitative Social
Sciences or come out of information and
public policy computational biology new
media so how do you constitute that how
do you maintain that culture of being
connected you've all seen these kind of
data you know I love the average class
sizes 23 units
we're probably now producing more data
science than the rest of the nation on
an annual basis already and we have only
there is a recent article that came out
of the business Higher Education Forum
you know two and a third million
postings last know two years ago but you
know two-thirds of employers expect that
this is essential to getting a job and
less than a quarter of university
leaders think that their graduates will
have those are we so in some sense so
this is you know how do we get to the
point where in the 21st century
every student graduating from college is
prepared to formulate and understand
arguments based on data thank
[Applause]
we have an online version of the classic
take it would take to move this to not
library so not the organized one every
one of the lecture videos is online and
available every one of the labs projects
lectures all of those are notebooks and
the materials are themselves the
textbook so I see this in many ways is
more valuable than the organized online
in this sphere because it allows people
really to pull it down I mean it's
different than the certification program
or the intense machine learning
experience so I actually think that's a
very valuable place right now it's
certainly been a question there's been
online programs that Anthony Joseph
offered through EDX on data bricks in
machine learning data science he
actually borrowed a lot of these
materials to integrate into his course
so there are now two and that was a
hundred and fifty thousand students so
it was it was pretty big but I think
it's actually a lot more valuable to get
these materials and techniques into the
universities themselves in person so
we're much more focused there we did do
a webinar that was co-sponsored by the
American Statistical Association in the
computer research Association CRA was
slow getting to it so all the slots
filled up on the ASI members so we had
about 250 schools most of which had half
a dozen faculty in the room watching it
together so it's moving pretty quickly
into faculty I mean Yale right rebranded
their statistics department I mean you
don't get much more conservative than
that so the the Dean of Social Sciences
that Yale came up and spent two days
with us really studying these things
Harvard is addicted to the connector
concept so that was another interesting
one we thought of it initially is this
appreciation to unit freshmen seminar
get a taste you know instead of doing
this little reading you could you could
allow students to understand what
cognitive science was like you know from
a more hands-on quantitative so that was
brilliant for a reason we didn't expect
if we had made those three units and
they would have had to go through all
sorts of approval hurdles but they were
these little foot in the door now large
fractions are saying well you know this
is really a three unit course but they
already own it they love it the students
love it and so then all of a sudden
accounts for students breadth
requirements and so the stuff is kind of
working its way up into satisfying
things for the students so that piece of
the subversive aspect was in hindsight
brilliant lectures some video and they
don't come across or even come across
yeah so that's been a question of how
best to do that and John De Niro when he
teaches the CEA's course the vast
majority don't come to class because
they're 2,500 of them we decided this it
was really important so we now do have
some mechanisms to bring students into
the classroom for the main lecture
there's still quite a mix but we decided
that it actually really is a lot of it
is pretty experiential and you get some
of it from the lecture but he it's
pretty amazing
this seeds enough questions that you can
do it's not flipped by any means but you
get opportunities where you can have a
buzz of students working through and
then sorting it out you kind of see it
in watching the lecture so we think that
that we're going to go to a thousand
next term and so you know that's pushing
it at that level
other questions yeah very good building
program animus or anything that you did
that in hindsight now feels so straining
or we should not done or done
differently so um the D s 150 feel that
this helical approach didn't work they
are really struggling they use really
interesting datasets and they spent too
much time trying to understand what the
heck was the data set so that's a
delicate mix there's there's aspects of
this that are quite labor intensive so
we were able to do it because it was so
much a labor of love but is that
replicable more generally not so clear
I'm pretty so I actually for you know I
might say connector should have been
three units so that they would be a
value to the students but actually it
was great that we didn't do that the
process of repurposing existing
requirements rather than creating new
ones was fabulous so you know that's one
and several times literally the
Chancellor would utter words or vice
chancellors of the data science
requirement and the antibodies just
kicked in
so you know it was harder more chaotic
to do it without that and to but I
really think it was the right thing to
do so I'm feeling pretty good about the
other you know nobody builds programs
from the bottom up they take the
graduate stuff and move it in the upper
division and then they move it down I I
wouldn't do it very many times but for
this doing it the other direction was
exactly right it does mean we're under
more than a little bit of pressure right
now to get those upper division courses
built
and you three years from now we might
argue that if we had approached it in a
more systematic way we would have got
those done more quickly whereas we'll
get it done more organically or slowly
but in place like Berkeley I don't think
we could have got it anywhere
any other way because the faculty are
all so headstrong that they won't let
anyone tell them what to do the big
question is we have a pretty rarefied
student body and you know this is still
true for Yale and Harvard and you know
so it'll be very interesting you know
UMass is a little different than us and
they're adopting these so they will get
more data about how broadly it
translates in the next few years but
right now we're feeling pretty good yeah
you see is great on perspective you're
basically but what this has is donation
expanding the coverage of certain topics
and it's another concern but I take away
the credit hours right so that what one
of the concept we should retire from our
history yeah so we still have an easy
entry right also this is a company
that's a completely different degree the
question shows up every model so when we
were doing the original Deseret the
rapid action we took testimony from a
bunch of majors and the general formula
is we create a major and then we fill it
up too with requirements until the
students plate is full and then we run
it like that forever and so for every
major the answer was we absolutely need
our students to know this and they
absolutely can't take any of these
courses and you go look at the data that
I showed you in the slides and the
answer is they are doing it anyways and
they're losing sleep over it so this
notion of actually trying to do more in
the same amount of time as work so now
they satisfy a statistics requirement
none of those had a computational
requirement but now while they're
satisfying their certificate get a
better statistics course and they learn
computing so uh there's it's you know we
are not perfectly efficient by any means
in the university so the idea that we
can't optimize everywhere anywhere is
pretty wild though the zero-sum game is
always where that conversation starts
you should be sure okay thank you all
[Applause]